make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with the
conclusion
of uh batman ghost stories right this is
the end of the batman ghost stories
story and i am a little bit on the fence
about how this ends but i'm also excited
at the same time
but overall the story was absolutely
amazing right and this is one of those
stories that one i urge you guys by
and two i'm going to i'm gonna buy the
physical copy of it but as you most you
guys know i only ever buy physical
copies of
comics if they're important to me at
this point in my life after having spent
so many years buying physical comics i
just got rid of my collection not just
by digitally now right it's just so much
easier than walking around with like you
know
20 comics at a time trying to read them
so uh so the first thing we do here
is we basically pick up with what is in
essence the final flashback
of the ghost stories story right in the
sense that we have batman and we have or
really bruce wayne we have a ghost maker
kind of having this conversation and the
interesting thing about this
is that bruce wayne kind of sees us
training as being completed right he's
basically done
and at this point he's ready to head
back to gotham city and become a crime
fighter and when he's met by ghost maker
the responsive ghost maker is
you're not ready and when he asks why
there's this really amazing conversation
that goes on between the two now for
ghost maker as a character
it's very easy to chalk him up where it
could have been very easy to chalk him
up as your stereotypical villain right a
guy who just does stuff and he's
essentially a vigilante and he's got no
regard for human life and nothing
matters or anything like that but the
reality is that while he does have a
disregard for human life his motivation
for it
is actually altruistic and i know that
sounds like an oxymoron how could you
believe in doing the right thing
because it's the right thing and at the
same time not care about people right
but one of the things to understand is
that doing the right thing does not
necessarily mean the preservation of
life those two things are not mutually
exclusive that in the world of like
utilitarianism for example
doing the best or at least the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
which could mean
sacrificing a few people and that's kind
of the stance of of ghost maker really
and and to kind of put a finer point on
it
that's his whole perception when he has
this conversation with batman he
basically says like you're not ready
here and when batman asks why
he says because the entire motivation
that you that you exist on
exists in two fronts the first is that
you're going back to gotham city to
fight crime because your mommy and your
daddy got shot
and you're that's your entire motivation
your motivation is external right you're
like a person that wants to lose weight
to impress a girl right as soon as he
has that girl impressed what's his
motivation to keep losing weight anymore
at that point like his entire motivation
is gone and he'll slump right back to
where he was before
when you get to a point where you
believe that like you're you finally
avenge the idea of your mom and your dad
then where does gotham city go from
there do you retire let it fall back
into the hands of those individuals who
corrupted in the first place what's
you know how does that how does that
whole end result the other part of that
is
in order for you to succeed you need an
internal motivation and that's
where he kind of outlines the difference
between himself and bruce wayne that
with bruce wayne
he wants to get basically it's vengeance
it's the most basic principle is
vengeance because his mom and dad were
mom and dad got shot and he's going to
get back at crime right he's not going
to get back an
individual person but he's going to get
packed at the entire principle of crime
for ghost maker
it's legitimately wanting to make the
world better it's truthfully
wanting to actually make the world a
better place it's really just
altruism at its finest now where the two
of them disagree
is the collateral damage that when when
ghost maker looks at batman he says the
problem that you have here
is that you basically let every small
little thing get to you
you know in this instance your mom and
dad were shot now you want to get back
at crime but the entire motivation is
that nobody will ever feel the same
thing you felt but what happens if they
do
what happens if you get to a crime scene
a minute to a minute later than it
actually happened what happens if you
can't stop that guy from pulling the
trigger and an innocent person dies
what happens well then now you see
yourself as a failure because you didn't
live up to your motivation right you
didn't live up to the cause that you
were supposed to be pushing on
at the same time you're basically
selfish right like i want to basically
make the world a better place we talked
about that you're just a really upset
kid who wants to go back and make gotham
a better place but the reality is
making the world better means not caring
about people
and again i know it sounds weird but
here's how he explains it right it's
actually a genius way
it's a really interesting way of doing
it his whole stance is if you don't
really care about people
then the ends justify the means and if
the end result is
basically what amounts to more or less a
utopian world where there really is no
crime because you're fighting the
concept on cr of crime
on multiple levels right you're fighting
it on the street level by putting away
criminals and then you're fighting it on
the various other levels in terms of why
people commit crimes you're basically
stimming it right so like you know
economic inequality different things
like that
you're fighting it all on multiple
fronts you know the idea of creating a
utopian style world outweighs the number
of people who died and that's true that
is a true statement if the end result is
that the world wouldn't
inherently become a utopian place not by
way of like some kind of fascism or
anything like that
but by people being able to just kind of
live their lives in peace not having to
worry about crime pursuing the things
they love the most right just kind of
enjoying their lives essentially
then it's worth the sacrifices of all
those individuals who were killed now it
doesn't mean that ghost maker is going
to go through and just murder
innocent people but it does mean that he
has to kind of disregard people right he
has to look at two circumstances and say
okay
i could stop this guy here from killing
that one person or i could let them kill
that one person
follow them back to their base of
operations which i don't know and then
get all the criminals at the same time
so i will sacrifice that one guy in
order to apprehend those bigger guys
right and it kind of sucks
but it's one of these things where when
it comes to the world of fighting crime
and trying to do better in the world
you can't have it all you can't have
your cake and eat it too you can't spare
the life
of the innocent guy and get all the
criminals at the same time more often
than not it doesn't work that way it'd
be nice if it did but the reality of the
world we live in is
you have to make choices and sometimes
these choices will be ones you don't
want to make but at the end of the day
what you're getting out of the choice
you make is better than what you're
losing in the choice that you're making
right so it's one of these interesting
interesting kind of philosophies
interesting situations but that's where
him and bruce wayne differ because bruce
wayne believes that he can have it all
right he can save the innocent guy and
he can topple the criminals and he can
kind of make all make the day better and
make every you know make gotham city a
much safer place the irony of all this
is that if you look at the history of
bruce wayne he's basically a dog chasing
his tail the criminals
never really get fixed they never really
get changed they're always bad guys
right he really hasn't made any headway
in making gotham better
if anything he's made gotham worse and
so that's kind of the irony here that's
kind of the the whole point that ghost
maker was trying to teach him is you're
not ready to actually do what needs to
be done
because you believe that you need to
save everybody when all the while the
reality is
some folks you're just gonna have to let
die in order to catch the bigger fish
it sucks it's not fair but nobody ever
said the world was and so because that
you know
ultimately you kind of have bruce wayne
and ghost maker just disagreeing and
going their separate ways right insofar
as
uh bruce wayne basically says fine i'm
going back to gotham city i don't ever
want to see you there and that's when
the truce gets struck
where ghost maker says okay fine then
that's the rule any city
that i'm currently in you do not come to
right if a city has been
seen by me right in the sense that like
i've been there i've involved myself
there then you never come there and i
will never go to any city that you've
touched foot in these are our own little
territories our own little places
wherever we set up shop
nobody else gets involved and so what we
end up doing is switching up to the
really
the end of the last video when clown
hunter intends to kill harley quinn and
that's kind of the funny thing here
right that you have this discussion
between these two guys or really just
kind of between batman and clown hunter
where batman tries to talk him down
the entire time this is going on ghost
maker is watching
all this unfold and and really the the
point that ghost maker was trying to
prove to batman is
if you put people in a circumstance
where there's no reward for doing the
right thing
but no consequence for doing the wrong
thing people will do the wrong thing
because more often than not the wrong
thing is easier the lazy user model and
the least effort principle right the
least ever principle was a concept
created by george ziff back in 1949
which basically said that like people
want the want the greatest reward for
the least amount of work the laser user
the lazy user model kind of builds on
that work now the idea of the lease ever
principle expands
way beyond more than simply just you
know work and reward and stuff like that
it actually
encompasses every facet of human and
really just every ecosystem in the world
right animal life plant life even
electricity things like that the path of
least resistance but it's kind of like
that grocery card litmus test i don't
know if you guys ever heard of that but
the grocery cart litmus test
is this concept in social psychology
where basically
it kind of answers the question what
would people do in a situation where
again
there's no reward for doing the right
thing but no consequence for doing the
wrong thing
and so if you have a grocery card and
you take it out you know you bring it
out to the parking lot you put all your
groceries in your car
uh there's no consequence nobody's gonna
arrest you or give you a ticket nothing
bad is gonna happen
if you just leave that grocery cart
sitting next to your vehicle and then
you pull out drive home
and that's it but you know it's the
right thing to do to put the grocery
cart back in the carousel
again it's a miniscule thing but
ultimately it's designed to kind of test
people and put them in a situation where
and where you ask the question what will
they do in this what will they do in
this situation
a lot of people leave the grocery cart
sitting next to their car which is
basically kind of a test of whether or
not people can actually self-govern
right well people do the right thing
even if there's no reward for doing the
right thing and the answer to that is
more often than not
no people usually won't that's the whole
point that ghost maker is creating here
for batman to
see that clown hunter has been given the
ability to kill harley quinn he can take
all his anger and all his all his
revenge
all his wrath out on harley quinn
because she was there when his parents
were killed at the hands of the joker
she's not the joker himself but
she's the closest the clown hunter can
get and so in this moment when clown
hunter is being talked to by batman and
clown hunter has the choice to either
walk away
or to kill harley quinn he goes in for
the kill and had batman not breaking
himself out of his bow out of his bonds
thrown his batarang at harley quinn
which she could in turn cut herself out
and then free herself before before con
hunter killed her and before bat you
know if batman had not been able to
subdue clown hunter harley quinn would
have been killed he would have been to
his baser instinct and the whole idea
behind this here this is what's
intriguing
is a whole idea behind this is that
while while clown hunter is kind of the
the minority here in so far that harley
quinn's turned over a new leaf
batman never really had a new leaf to
turn over in the first place but he's
always taken the high road i would
surmise these two
are the exception to the rule and not
the rule itself and the reason why is
simple harley quinn
creates this case for us where she
basically starts talking to him and
saying hey look i was a psychiatrist let
me talk to you for a second right and
almost talks to him like a patient she
says look there's something you need to
understand
right hear me out and then when i'm done
talking you can kill me if you really
want to and so he's like okay fine
and one of the things she basically says
here is i'm not really responsible for
the things that i did and it's not
really said in so many words but it's
basically i was at a point in my life
where i was at a really really really
low place
right i was in a really bad spot and
then suddenly a man came along who told
me everything that i wanted to hear
that made me feel special that made me
feel relevant in a world
where i felt painfully irrelevant and i
got carried away with it but the crazy
thing about this is one thing to
understand with harley quinn
she wasn't hypnotized she wasn't tricked
she wasn't mind controlled she was
manipulated to a degree but at the same
time
she also understood the consequences of
her actions she knew that she was doing
the wrong thing
we know that she knows she was doing the
wrong thing because over the course of
her publication history she recognized
the problem she had and actually tried
to leave the joker
but kept going back but if she
understands the problem but then makes
temporary efforts to fix the problem but
then ultimately relapses then that means
she is responsible for her actions
because she understands that what she's
doing is wrong and so because of that
the the kind of argument of well i'm not
really
responsible for what i did i mean i'm
sorry that your your parents died but
it's not really my fault at the end of
the day
it still is and she understands that
when she goes as far as to say like i
made a lot of mistakes
i did a lot of things that i shouldn't
have done and i'm going to pay those
consequences for the rest of my life but
i'm just trying to be a better version
of myself
right and you know when she sits down
and offers a kind of apology to kevin
you know that's really all he gets out
of her in reality that's all he really
can get out of her and initially it
doesn't seem to be enough and he
actually intended looks like he intends
to go in for the kill but then
essentially doesn't right he actually
just doesn't really kill harley quinn
and so that
moment of an apology seems to be enough
for him to kind of say okay i need to be
on my own and rethink things now the
reality of this is that if this was in
the real world harley quinn would have
died because if we had a situation where
somebody had killed your parents
in a violent crime and then in turn
showed up to you and said hey
i'm sorry i killed your parents at some
future point in time that wouldn't be
enough
right i mean an apology is all you get
that wouldn't be enough right i mean
we'd be screaming for blood right eye
for an eye you know and so he
you know any normal person would have
stabbed her to death and that's why i
think the the philosophy of ghost maker
rings true
it really does ring true here because
where where clown hunters like okay fine
you know all right you know i gotta get
where you're coming from
again it's all the exception to the rule
that under any normal circumstance they
would have lashed out and they would
have attacked them and so for the most
part the batman comics in terms of how
they're being shown here
are very optimistic which is kind of
ironic given how pessimistic the city of
gotham is
and that's one of the reasons why ghost
maker being involved here
makes things so intriguing because ghost
maker's stance on this is i could catch
that boy if i wanted to and then he goes
so far as to ask batman what were you
trying to prove there
by by having this by convincing this kid
or getting this kid to listen to harley
quinn
and then walk away from the idea of
killing her what do you believe that
you've proved here and the stance of
batman is i'm it's not about proving
anything
right like i just genuinely care about
the kid and i didn't want to see him
ruin his life but the other thing that
you kind of have to ask here is that if
you look at somebody like ghost maker
and you say okay
this is a guy who approached the world
with the idea that the world can
legitimately be saved and killing
criminals is a small price to pay for
the betterment of the billions of people
across the face of the world then in
turn
the question has to be asked how did he
get to that point and how does he
maintain that position
is he really just that obstinate right
is he really just that unwilling to
listen to reason
or if he's really as intelligent as
bruce wayne believes he is and is really
as intelligent as we're being told he
is then he has to have come across
different situations over the course of
his life
that reaffirmed the idea that if
villains are given a choice between
reforming or staying villains
they'll stay villains right because it's
either what they're used to it's easier
but people will
be more likely to commit a crime to
achieve a goal than they will be to
actually work hard right again
the least effort principle that people
want the greatest reward for the least
amount of work that they can do and so
because of that like a fight kind of
breaks out between the two of them you
know kind of this this final fight that
we get and batman goes as far as to say
like do you know how many times
i could have killed harley quinn over
the years right how many how easy it
would have been to just
eliminate joker's closest associates but
then nobody learns nobody changes
nothing's better in the end now the
response of ghost maker is
not everyone can be safe and the
response of batman is
but most people can and you usually
cannot tell when you're face to face
with them
on the worst day of their life but
here's the irony about all that right
this is why i advocate for the joker
being killed by batman
in comics obviously come back at some
point online but it's why i think
killing the joker and gotham is the only
right thing to do
because this assumes that the person
you're facing off against
is a person of reasonable rational sound
mind who is
otherwise taken into a situation that
they normally wouldn't put themselves in
right like a husband loses his job and
in order to make ends meet he robs a
bank to buy food to feed his family
that's a very tangible
and realistic scenario that we see
unfolding even now out there in the
world now if batman would have come
across that guy
while he's robbing that bank in that
moment of desperation then batman's
statement rings true
like you cannot really you can't see
people for how great they can be when
you're seeing them
in the worst day of their life right
that moment of desperation
but the thing about the joker is he's
always been crazy the joker's not a guy
well i guess ever since he became the
joker but the joker's not a guy where he
gets up in the morning he gets a cup of
coffee he watches the morning news
and he says okay time to go be crazy and
then he just goes and does crazy stuff
the joker's crazy 24
hours a day he sleeps crazy right he
eats crazy you know he like he is
constantly crazy he is beyond being
helped
any possible help any reformation any
fixing him is a pipe dream
this idea of batman saying like the
average person can be fixed they can be
say that's true
because harley quinn was not nearly as
crazy as a joker she wasn't nearly as
lost as the joker was there was always
that portion of her that knew that she
was doing the wrong thing and batman
could tap into that and always try to
find a way to bring her back
even if she wasn't readily accepting of
it with a joker that's gone
any semblance of humanity the joker
previously had any semblance of
rationality outside of whatever it is
that i can do to get batman to chase me
is the thing that i will do that's gone
the joker is is really like he's not
really even human anymore
right and so because of that there's no
saving him there's no point where batman
will ever come across the situation and
say okay
now i've quote unquote fix the joker
he's back to being a rational person
everything will be safe i guess the
white knight might work and so far as
like feeding him joker pills right but
in terms of organically getting him back
to being normal that's never going to
happen
and so as long as the joker's alive the
joker will do everything he can to get
batman to chase him and because of his
his his psychosis and because of his uh
his being a sociopath he has a complete
and total disregard for the thoughts
feelings emotions
and and lies of other people right
they're irrelevant to him
their pawns in this game that he plays
with batman and so the only way to save
people from the joker is to kill the
joker the fact that batman's never done
that yet really
says volumes about batman's stance on
sacrificing innocent people
on behalf of keeping the joker alive
right it is a reverse version of
utilitarianism but done
in a perverse way and that's that's
something that i wanted to clear that's
why i advocate for the joker being
killed
in light of all that i don't really see
how any rational person could advocate
for the joker staying alive and saying
batman shouldn't kill him right at this
point
it's just the right thing to do and so
it's one of these things where batman
kind of gives up the fight with ghost
maker says look we've been fighting long
enough right we've been fighting and
fighting and fighting and fighting and
in all reality i've got my place here
you've got your place there wherever it
is
you happen to be i'm tired of fighting
you i'm tired of doing this and so in
response like batman starts to put his
guard back on and ghost maker kind of
says you know i always kind of wished
you'd come charging at me with one of
your cars right i was always jealous of
your cars i always thought they were
cool
you know and batman's like i'm building
a new one he's like is it a flying car
it's like nope
it's just a wheels on the ground car
right because remember joker um batman's
lost pretty much all his wealth right
he's not really as wealthy as he used to
be uh he
all that money has been seized right i
mean well i guess really lucius fox is
the one that runs wayne enterprises but
bruce wayne himself is no longer in his
company right that was one of the big
fallout
fallout aspects of joker war it really
is just him and his wits
and you know using whatever resources he
can to do whatever it is that he can
but ultimately ghost maker is like okay
fine then i'll be watching you on the
ghost net right i'll be keeping an eye
on you in your city
because i'm curious to see are you
really going to be able to stem the flow
of crime here in gotham or are you going
to be like you've always been a dog
chasing his tail wondering why things
aren't getting better but then batman
stops him and says you don't actually
have to leave here
right like i mean this truce that we
have is there because we really have
more respect for each other and it's
more of a rivalry than outra outright
hatred for each other
but at the end of the day we both
respect the other's ability right you
bring
a level of skill to gotham that nobody
else in the bat family has
and between you and me we complement
each other exceedingly well
so come to come to gotham city like come
help me save this city right if you
believe that i could do things better
then show me how to do things better
right don't kill anybody in my city but
let's make things better
we can fight crime on a multitude of
different levels right we can do it in a
myriad of different ways and so
initially
the response of ghost maker is man i
don't i don't really know about that
batman's like come on dude like what do
you have to lose and so ultimately
ghost maker accepts ghost maker accepts
and joins batman
in gotham city and becomes part of the
bad family now here's the thing i'm kind
of
i'm i'm excited about this right i'm a
little iffy on how it ends
because of the fact that like we're not
gonna find out until march which kind of
pisses me off
but i do like the idea of ghost maker i
love the character of ghost maker he's
amazing i absolutely adore the character
of ghost maker um i think it's one of
the most interesting additions to the
bat family that's been done in recent
years when i say recent years since like
grant morrison's run
right like since batman incorporated i
think it's cool and maybe even before
batman incorporated i think ghost maker
is probably one of the most interesting
characters ever introduced to the batman
mythos i'm really excited to see where
it goes but the reason why we have to
wait until march is because next month
we get future state so yes we are
getting the future state event and dc
comics
with uh the future batwing the son of
lucius fox i'm excited about this
what i'm excited about about the new
batman coming and the new new future
state batman comics but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
uh if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i wanna
know what you guys think about this
story right leave a comment down in the
description
and uh or in the comment section rather
and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you